Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be a video
All about how Jon Snow is related to the white
walkers and the night King on the TV show
so just careful for spoilers for everything
this happen on the show so far there couple
key ideas and understanding the differences
between the show and the books the night King
on the TV show is a little bit different from
the character in the books so I'll try to
explain those Backstories a little bit as
well.
There is a new round of the game of thrones
giveaway it's for one of the enhanced editions
of the books.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so that
you don't miss anything.
A lot of you asked about the history of the
night King on the TV show because a lot of
book readers have known about the nights king
from old man's tales for a long time, so a
lot of the lower of game of thrones is told
orally through other characters like old man
that tell legends of people like the 13th
Lord Commander of the nights watched will
became the first nights king the legend is
old man tells it is that that Lord Commander
was a start of winter fell brother to the
king of winter at the time.
Remember how the TV show compresses things
though.
So you have to imagine that there have been
many many white walkers that have been sacrificed
as children in the books.
There have also probably been many nights
king's to have taken up the mantle of the
leader of the white walkers there has to be
someone to create other white walkers.
Although they have an implied any real organizational
structure yet.
So is 13th Lord Commander that Nan says was
the first nights king was probably just at
that time the newest leader of the white walkers
that there was also probably want to proceed
him the way they explain the tale is actually
pretty fantastic, they make it sound like
not long after the creation of the wall.
The 13th Lord Commander this mythical start
fell in love with the woman north of the wall
with skin is white as the moon and eyes like
blue stars.
So she herself may have been a White Walker
the way they described them in the books is
having this otherworldly beauty the TV show
is made them pretty ugly and fearsome so is
a lot more plausible that someone would fall
in love with a beautiful looking white Walker
rather than someone that looks like this when
they consummated their relationship.
He himself became a White Walker.
They returned to the night for which is not
Castle Black it's one of the other forts along
the wall a rule there for 13 years till an
alliance of Brandon the breaker one of the
further kings of winter.
Your money can be on the wall at the time
join forces to defeat him, so presumably after
that if you believe the legend and what George
R Martin has told us through old man's tales
after that nights king died another leader
of the white walkers was selected and created.
So there's this nice symmetry with the way
there are Lord commanders of the nights watched
when one dies, another one is anointed, the
same thing happening with the white walkers
as well, but the difference in the TV show
is that there's only been this one night King
they imply that he was the one that we saw
in the flashback that we still see today the
way bran refers to him is that it's the same
person this whole time, and he's lived for
some odd thousand years.
Now this is the time of the first men when
there were still kings of winter like you
could call Jon Snow king of winter king in
the North, but you have to remember that before
the and those invaded which is about 6000
years ago in the books.
The first men rain.
They were still kings in different regions.
So you have people like land the clever who
started house Lannister you have Brandon the
builder who helped build the wall.
Also found house stark during the age of heroes.
So, were talking upwards of 10,000 years ago
in the books the TV show has compressed that
timeline so that it was about a thousand years
ago.
So the way George R Martin tells it is that
his mythical nights king is a legendary figure,
it's no more likely to have survived to present
day that land the clever or Brandon the builder.
So another lot of conspiracy.
There is there like what if Brienne is Brandon
the builder because of his time traveling
abilities everything that George RR Martin
has implied is that those mythical ancient
figures really did exist thousands of years
ago is powerful is bran's magic is there's
no big twist beyond the stuff that you've
seen so far.
I mean there's some powers that he has that
you haven't seen but it's not like he went
back to help build the wall the TV show changes
a lot of things they could take a few liberties
with that they imply the people in the past
like young Ned Stark at the tower of joy can
hear when bran calls out, but they're purposefully
very ambiguous about that is that they never
have to answer that question outright, but
even though TV show nights king is different
from George R Martin's nights king the leaf
character explains to bran how they created
the white walkers after he has the vision
of the first men being turned into the night
King she explains that they had to create
something to get rid of the first men.
He was about 12,000 years ago after the first
men invaded west roast they had this big war
with the current inhabitants the children
of the forest who lived way further south
than they do now.
They signed a pact with the first men on the
Isle of bases to end the war, which is actually
this island right here is one of the few places
left in the South has Weirwood's that's with
a call the Isle of faces because the faces
on the Weirwood's all of house stark descendents
from the first men.
So it makes sense that someone from the North
up near this location here this is been a
very far north where bran is seeing this tree.
Probably not too far from the Bloodraven street
like you remember the night King made that
ornate formation with all the heads of the
dead horses and the men near the fist of the
first men, so a lot of white Walker children
of the force history is localized to the North
because that's where they went after the pact
of the first men.
So it makes sense on a practical level the
Starks share blood with this.
First, men who became the night King of the
TV show, but also from a somatic perspective
where you have him tied to Jon Snow who is
the song of ice and fire himself the whole
idea is about the narrative of balance.
So wouldn't it be that much more meaningful
if the thing that you are fighting the evil
thing shared some blood with you shared some
common genetic material.
So it makes sense that the Starks share DNA
with this night King that when you talk about
the ancient 13th Lord Commander night King,
even if old man is embellishing about the
dates about how big figures were and about
how events went down there are still a lot
of Starks going back thousands of years that
joined the nights watched there were others
that previously became Lord's Commander when
Jon Snow was named Lord Commander of the nights
watched he is almost the thousandth Lord Commander,
so I would choose to believe old man, even
though a lot of legends do get embellished
there is common DNA between this night King.
Even some of the white walkers which are actually
mostly Craster sons on the TV show right now
is just because a lot of the surviving DNA
of the first men lives on in the peoples of
the North, most of the people south of the
wall dissent from the angles.
Although there was the war between the animals
in the first men.
So there was likely some intermarrying between
those peoples for the most part the blood
of the first men as you would call it lives
on in the people of the North as well as the
free folk north of the wall and in the people
way further than that fence that also share
the blood of the first men.
So Craster free full just shares blood of
the first men share some DNA in common with
the Starks of winter fell.
So that means that the white walkers here
are all related to Jon snow in some way King's
blood is something different though it's important
to Melisandre there might also be important
to the creation of new nights king's and until
George R Martin tells us otherwise you have
to assume that the night King is created in
the same way that we saw happen on the TV
show Dragon glass plunged into the heart of
a first men.
Now they don't explain whether or not the
blood of the first men is important in this,
but there's some more magical components that
they haven't explained yet like if you stab
someone with a Dragon glass dagger in the
heart it would probably just die.
So there's a whole bunch of magic that the
TV show has not explained yet but we don't
fully understand what's going on with the
red God we just know about the things that
Melisandre is been able to do the other things
that the red priests in the books have been
able to do this is all stuff that George RR
Martin will spell out in much greater detail
in the books.
So if you're new to the books.
That's why it's really important to read those
things but don't worry, that's also what I
make videos forced explain this really cool
stuff, but hopefully that explains a little
about why it's important that the Starks share
some DNA with this night King on the TV show
just because of the proximity effect of went
he was created and when the first men settled
in that area and created house stark and when
the wall was built please leave all your request
for future game of thrones videos in the comments
below will have another one posting later
this week I'll be updating my video schedule
on the about page of my YouTube channel.
Congratulations to the new game of thrones
giveaway winner Seth Nicholson please private
message me on the back end of my channel so
I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a game of thrones video tonight,
the be some new Justice league Aqua man behind
the scene stuff posting what you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to learn
about the brand-new Targaryen book George
R Martin is publishing at the end of the year
you can click here for my Arya stark season
seven predictions.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
five I'll see you in the next video!